all right everybody
this is the reuben report direct message
i'm dave rubin in case you don't know me
i assume you know me because you're
probably watching this on youtube or on
the blaze
and we've been doing stuff in both those
places for quite some time
this is going to be my new semi
daily kind of daily almost fully daily
three day a week
news show we're going to be doing this
every tuesday
wednesday and thursday at 11 a.m
pacific which is 12 1 2 p.m
eastern where we'll be streaming on
youtube and
on the blaze tv where i'm going to be
talking about the news in hopefully a
bit of a different way
as many of you know i just came back
from
a month off the grid i had no news
no current events no nothing related to
all of the political madness that we're
all dealing with all the time
and i do this every august this is the
fourth august that i've done it and i've
done it
because i find that a little time away
helps not only refresh me but give me a
little perspective
on all of the stuff that we're
constantly fighting about right that
everybody everybody is waking up
and screaming about and arguing about
and it's leaking into every part of
society whether it's the sports world or
the video game world or your
knitting club or whatever else you do
maybe for fun and to escape it it seems
that
politics and the endless fight
has leaked into absolutely everything
and what i wanted to try to do
and why i was willing to partner with
the blaze
on doing uh a more of a daily type show
was that i want to give people an
opportunity to know about the issues of
the day but not become
absolutely obsessed with the little
minutia
of every story and the endless
battle that is keeping us all kind of
crazy so if anything i want this show
uh the direct message to be an antidote
to some of that stuff and i'll be very
frank and honest and open about how
we're gonna be doing this show
uh this is gonna be me and my producer
michael we're gonna wake up
in the morning we're gonna send each
other a couple texts couple emails
what's going on
in the world what are the two or three
things that i think
are worth discussing with you guys and i
say discussing with you because although
i'm the one talking into the camera here
uh i do want this
to be a discussion and sometimes we'll
do some q a stuff and you guys can
submit
questions at rubinreport.com and
sometimes we'll
we'll skype in some guests not for
interviews that are going to
be uh the same way we do them with the
reuben report that still is going to
exist as
is we're going to be doing as many shows
as we've ever done
for the traditional reuben reports sit
down but i might do smaller interviews
or just little quicker hit
type things to help frame a story help
find somebody that can
tell me about a story in a new way or
has a fresh perspective
or is on the ground in a specific place
or something like that
but i thought the best way that i could
kick off this
new series this new show would be to
talk about
some of the things that i missed in
august so i'm sure many of you saw it
but just yesterday i got back on the
grid
on september 1st after 31 days away it
was just heavenly i can't
possibly recommend anything more um and
michael knowles over at the daily wire
uh brought me back onto the grid twice
before i've had ben shapiro bring me
back on and then last year glenn beck
brought me on knowles brought me on this
year and basically
he sat down and over the course of two
hours
enlightened me on everything that i
missed and you know the interesting
thing about this year of course is that
i don't know if you know this but we're
in an election year uh but of course
there was the
uh there was the rnc convention there
was the dnc convention
uh biden named kamala harris uh his vp
which i did not know about
until yesterday but suffice to say there
was
a lot of political stuff on top of the
uh pandemic that you may have heard
about and the race riots
and the protests and the burning down
the burning down of cities and
things of that nature so there was a lot
and part of me was like
man can i can i even do this can i even
go off the grid this year
there's so much happening it's so
important it's it's so vital it feels
like
the very fabric of our nation is being
torn apart it feels like
we're like debating whether america or
western civilization
or freedom uh are these good things or
not i mean these are
crazy debates we seem to be having um
and i was like i don't know if i can
really go off the grid but that if
anything was more of the reason
to do it so knowles yesterday uh caught
me up to speed on everything we actually
couldn't get to all of the
crazy stories that he wanted to get to
but my team had been tracking everything
throughout the month and i have caught
up on
absolutely everything i missed
everything from kamala harris
as vp to this whap song by cardi b
and i'm not going to repeat any of that
right now but if you want to hear me
slightly
rapping or reading it basically for the
first time this whap song you can find
that
in the video i did with knowles
yesterday which is probably somewhere
right down
below this video so what i thought i
would do for today
is i'm just going to take the five
stories that i think are the most
important things over the course of the
month and as i said we'll be doing this
tuesdays wednesdays and thursdays and
each morning i'll just be picking two or
three stories
i'll give you my perspective i'm not
going to try to manipulate you
or lie to you i'm going to try to give
you as honest and
fresh and decent a take as possible
without making you angry
i'm going to try to do it in a way that
hopefully will be somewhat shareable
so if you're arguing with the friend
you're able to just send them
this video and then you can say hey
here's a guy that seems to me to be you
know halfway decent maybe a bit of a
centrist
and you know maybe take a look at
something that maybe
isn't the type of thing that you would
normally look at so for today i'm just
going to recap the five things that i
missed
and then really starting tomorrow we're
just going to be diving into
whatever the big issues of the day are
and by the way they won't always purely
be political
you know i talk about this all the time
but one of the big problems we have is
that everything is becoming political so
you watch an nba game and then it's a
black lives matter
protest and that that is a problem
because we need some spaces where things
aren't political so there might be
stories that are more
culturally relevant than say purely
political
um there might be a pure story uh sports
story
that is separate from politics
altogether that would be really nice
actually
but that might have some some bigger
meaning to it that might be worth
talking about and we'll also try to find
some funny stuff and some silly stuff
and throw in some memes and some of the
some of the stuff that's going viral
and all that stuff so okay we're gonna
do the the the top five
things that dave rubin missed during his
august off the grade so i already
referenced the first one the
the big one i suppose uh in the
political world at least is that joe
biden announced that kamala harris
is going to be his vice presidential
candidate this is a couple weeks ago
already but again i did not know it
until
until yesterday now i will be uh quite
frank
i did suspect it because you may
remember that at the end of july
it leaked in politico that
biden was choosing harris and they
already even had a quote from biden
about harris
and then when it leaked then they sort
of backtracked the implication being oh
you know we have these sort of
statements ready to go in case it's any
other person and this one just happened
to leak
so i sort of suspected it was kamala
harris and let's not forget of course
that for a year biden has been saying
that his choice would
absolutely be a female so you know this
is the guy that's supposed to fight
identity politics on the left
but he was choosing you know he was
eliminating
half of the population in effect or half
of the viable candidates
uh just by their gender uh and then it
became obvious and he had sort of been
hinting at it over the last couple weeks
that not only would the nominee be
female but it would be a person of color
so that then
whittled it down further so you're not
going to get uh elizabeth warren who
unfortunately for her doesn't count as
native american
um and then that that really left
probably an
african-american woman uh so between the
political article and the contextual
clues
and the fact that i was at the
supermarket about two weeks ago and i
was getting a watermelon
and there was a woman screaming about
kamala harris i did have a sense
that it was going to be kamalahara so
there's a couple interesting things
about the kamala choice here now first
off
it doesn't quite feed the crazed
lefty purely progressive marxist
whatever you want to call it
base because they didn't like her they
think of her as more of like a
corporatist hillary clinton type meaning
that if you wanted to go
that route and just feed the base then
you would have gone with an elizabeth
warren or you would have picked a
freaking aoc
or ilhan omar rashida to leave i mean
some one of these
really just terrible people who are who
are promulgating some of the worst ideas
in society now
but biden chose not to do that or i i
shouldn't say biden the
the dnc or whoever's in charge there
chose not to do that they went a little
more mainstream let's say now what's
interesting about this is
kamala harris a lot of people thought
she might be the nominee but then once
the
debates started she never got any
traction she had a good
first debate but basically never showed
anything in the polls and then was out
way quicker
than anyone thought so she has no real
support right the far lefties
that are the base of the party they
don't like her and then when the party
went out to vote in their own primaries
it's not like
she ever did well she never did well so
it's it's a strange pick in that regard
but it did fill the buckets that he was
going for which were woman and
african-american and that's just a sad
reality look the the thing with kamala
is that i believe her to be a dangerous
politician what a dangerous politician
is is someone who wants to use
power right who gets into office and
then says it doesn't matter what the
system
allows for what checks and balances are
why we have
three branches of government but i want
to use my office for power
purely for power and bring as much power
to my office as possible
whether that would be a republican or a
democrat or anything else that's what i
would always be worried about now kamala
harris to me
is one of those types of people there is
a moment that i've brought up several
times and i've tweeted about it a couple
times
during the debates when she was still in
it
where a question was asked to joe biden
about whether he would do an executive
action
on guns now an executive action means
that instead of going through the
legislative branch instead of going
through
congress and the senate to write a law
which the president just signs
an executive action is sort of a
loophole that they have to get around
this they're really not supposed to use
it but all presidents do
but you can't use an executive action to
step on
a god-given right meaning a right that's
enshrined in the constitution
in this case the bill of rights our
second amendment is about the right to
bear arms
and in effect uh what biden said when
asked this question would you
use an executive action to
limit gun purchases it was something
around guns right
he said well it would have to be
constitutional and
there was pretty much silence from the
crowd and and that really does tell you
a bit about the base there because you'd
think that would that was the right
answer it's the true answer you can't do
things that are unconstitutional
kamala harris then laughed in his face
and sort of cackled and she goes oh
joe can't we just say yes we can
and this is seriously dangerous the
thinking behind
that meaning that once i have the power
or the perceived power
to do something or just because i've
been voted in president
the idea is that i can use that power to
limit
another right that is enshrined in the
bill of rights in the constitution
this is a this is a huge problem and i
know that's just one little
snippet although there's many other
snippets of her desire to use power the
amount of people that she put in jail
for
smoking marijuana in california and a
bunch of other stuff but that one little
snippet i think
is uh is really indicative of what the
problem is
with the democrats right now because
biden mentioned the constitution but
the base doesn't really care about the
constitution and then he chose
a vice president who clearly
doesn't care about it so on top of the
fact that i i don't think that they have
much
really uh lined up together in terms of
ideas or anything else it's hard to tell
what any of the democrats
think at this point that's just an
unfortunate reality but
i'm really really worried about that
because i've been saying this for months
but if you
are a democrat and you're going to vote
for joe biden you just got to know with
the cognitive stuff which is just a sad
reality and by the way the scandal
is not that he's having cognitive
problems everyone knows that he is
the scandal is that they're hiding it
and the damn will break one day and
they're all going to turn on each other
oh he told me i couldn't say it he told
me i couldn't say it but we all know
it's there right so the scandal is the
non-scandal
um but you have to know that if you're a
democrat and you're voting
for joe biden in effect you're voting
for kamala harris or you're voting for
the party apparatus that put her there
so i think it's a pretty dangerous one
so that was one story that happened
uh number two uh and i'll do these both
as one story i'll be a little
a little briefer oh i should tell you by
the way we're gonna try to do most
of these uh direct messages in 24
minutes i don't need to give you six
hours
of babbling on about everything we're
going to try to do them in 24 minutes
and and see where the chips fall can i
can i make some sense of the world in 24
minutes
instead of 20 minutes people used to do
things in 20 minutes 20 20
was 20 20 20 minutes give us 60 minutes
we'll say
that was something else all right either
way i'm going to try to do them in 24
minutes
so the other the other two sort of
political things of course that happened
were the conventions so there was the
rnc convention
and the dnc convention uh i caught up in
uh this morning and last night watching
a bunch of clips from them and i did a
bunch of reading on both
and in essence everything that that i've
talked about on this show about the
direction that the world seems to be
going in
was really on display um at both of
these conventions
either you believe in identity politics
you believe that we should be judged on
our immutable characteristics and our
gender and our sexuality
and that that really is the thing that
is most important and if it is most
important
then we then must disassemble the entire
system here in america
that is so inherently evil and awful
even though everyone still wants to come
here and nobody wants to leave and
capitalism has brought more wealth
and equality to more people and and how
truly great our system is
and by the way if you're if you're
thinking if you're watching this and
you're thinking it ain't great well i
gotta tell you
uh think about your grandparents and i
guarantee you you had it
you have it a lot better than they did
or your great-grandparents or your
ancestors before them we've done
something really right in america and
that seems to be on trial
right now and that that is a big problem
but in essence we had a democratic
convention where they in a weird way
have to run
against everything america was and is
right so they have to run against
america was because they believe that
the whole system is racist and it was
founded on this
bad set of ideas and they have to run on
what it is because now trump is involved
so that's the is we have the was and
there is
and then you had the republican
convention which
actually was pretty freaking pro-america
and was pro-capitalism and was pro
freedom
and and had some diversity of thought i
don't even care about the the other
diversity stuff
um and that really is the choice that
we're all left with making and for those
of you
uh you know obviously i have a lot of uh
conservatives now that watch this show
and a lot of libertarians that watch
this show
but i know that i have a lot of
disaffected liberals
that are on a similar journey that i've
been on for these last couple years
and we we aren't all at the same places
in this but i think for us
which i think is a huge swath of people
in america we're going to have to decide
which way
is going to forge a future that's going
to be more in line with the things that
we believe and i think it's just
becoming obvious
that that is a center-right future so
we had the we had the conventions and
now we have we have two months
two months to figure out uh what
will potentially be the biggest
presidential race ever they say it every
four years but this one really feels
like it right like this one
does this feel more important or less
important than like obama versus romney
right or mccain versus obama or like
those
it sort of felt like oh okay you guys
view the world a little bit differently
but like we kind of get it america's
good we'll see what happens
now it's like are we going to be
capitalist or socialist
are we going to just let there be no
rule of law or some rule of law like
the big stuff is up for debate right now
and it's going to be a wild two months
and i'll talk about this i'm sure many
times over the next couple of months but
whether
whether both sides or either side will
even respect the
the decision the outcome of the election
is going to start becoming a huge thing
in maryland voting in the rest of it
um of course i have to talk a little bit
about the protests and the violence
and you know what's been happening in
portland and seattle and has
shifted over uh till to milwaukee and a
whole bunch of other
uh cities and states i mean look in
essence
um we can have an honest conversation
about racism we can have an honest
conversation about policing we can look
at numbers
we can see the realities or we can just
burn everything down and we can burn
down
statues and cities and just in the last
couple days
the mayor of portland ted wheeler who
kept saying that the peaceful protesters
are peaceful and it's peaceful peaceful
peaceful
well you know what they did just i
believe it was yesterday they
they went to his house and started
attacking his house now he's probably
leaving his house he's not going to live
there anymore so suddenly not so
peaceful
that's also similar to the mayor of
seattle who kept saying the whole thing
was peaceful
chop it's peaceful even though an
insurgent group decided that there's a
you know a certain square block area of
her own city that no one else can go
into
but then they showed up at her house
suddenly not so peaceful anymore
this is what playing with fire looks
like if you kind of tell
antifa and black lives matter activists
and these marxists if you keep telling
them oh you can
kind of do your thing and just you know
don't bring it over to my backyard
you're tacitly endorsing them
to bring it to your uh to your backyard
and that's what we got to watch out for
so
the protests have continued and again i
think we're at a place now
where it's sort of like are you for law
and order or not
even if people tearing down statues have
good intentions and i'm not so sure of
that and i i would prefer that these
statues not be
taken down and i put up counter
monuments and things like that or
placards whatever it might be
uh even if you think they have good
intentions without law and order we have
nothing
we absolutely have nothing so we've got
to figure out a way
to get past some of this stuff and have
some honest conversations hey that's why
i'm doing this show so there you go
number four number four the pandemic
fell all the way down to number four
um look it's a little hard to tell what
the hell is going on
with this thing at this point there's a
study just in the last couple days that
has been released
that has said that only six percent of
the people who have been
been declared dead because of
coronavirus exclusively died of
coronavirus that they actually had
co-morbidity meaning they had
other things that they were sick with
and would have died within a limited
amount of time
i mean every day we just find out
something else and i think the bigger
issue than the virus i mean if you think
about
think about it this way if if everything
that's going on right now is affecting
you meaning it's affecting your job it's
affecting your family everyone's home
now you're
not at your business you're not at your
place work et cetera et cetera is it the
virus itself that's affecting you
not to diminish the realities of the
virus or
is it the government reaction to it
which is not letting people go to work
not letting people go to restaurants and
things of that nature now
look i'm here in l.a we're highly highly
regulated i got yelled at as i was
walking into the drugstore
i was putting my mask on right at the
door because it was really hot out and i
didn't want to walk around with a hot
mask
on my face and some guy started yelling
at me that i was about to walk into the
store without a mask even though i
literally had it in my hand and i was
about to put it on
um we have to decide
whether the lockdown and all of the
measures being taken
are right or not but but the issue is we
seem unable to have an honest
conversation about that just like we
can't have an honest conversation about
race
at least we're just not doing it that
well and the problem is that the people
that are
governing us say andrew cuomo who's been
seen walking his dog outside without a
mask on
or nancy pelosi up in san francisco who
just in the last few days
was found at her beauty salon getting
her hair cut which is illegal
even by her own by her own edict
in effect but she said she didn't even
know what the law was and didn't even
realize and they closed the place down
for her and all that
and we're pretty much at that marie
antoinette let them eat cake
thing you know like we're at that moment
where it's like the the
elite are saying we're gonna live one
way
and we're also gonna wreck the entire
system so you will have to become more
dependent on us so we'll have to give
you more handouts
so that you'll just be okay that is that
is antithetical to how
this entire system is supposed to work
these people work for us they are not
our
they are not our masters okay if
anything we're their masters
i would prefer we all just be equal um
but that's the honest conversation that
we're gonna have to start having
is there is going to be some risk in
opening up more
absolutely i am not sitting here telling
you that coronavirus is a hoax
or anything of the nate of that nature
what i am saying is we have to have
honest conversations
especially in places where look as i
said i'm hearing la
everyone out is is fairly young when you
go outside you see young people that are
healthy and the sun is shining and it's
90 degrees
and you've got all these young people
not only not at restaurants because you
can't go to restaurants but covering up
in other places
and maybe we're never going to get to
herd mentality a herd mentality we don't
want to be in heard mentality we're
probably there
but we're never going to get to herd
immunity because we won't let enough
people get sick and then build some
antibodies in the rest of it so we've
got
serious work to do and in the final
minute here
somehow peace in the middle east showed
up guys israel signed a historic peace
deal
with the united arab emirates and now
just over the last day or so we're
hearing that there could be four or five
more arab countries that are going to
sign deals
uh with with israel there's an
incredible video of netanyahu who's the
prime minister of israel
having a phone call in hebrew with an
official at the united arab emirates i
mean it's it's staggering stuff
the media is kind of hiding it because
it has something to do with orange man
so it must be bad but i thought peace
was good i thought peace is what we were
going for
and uh and it's incredibly uh
exciting actually and and really really
good and
seriously under reported so these are
just some of the things that are going
to frame a lot of what we're going to be
talking about
in the next year i'm super psyched to be
working
with the blaze on this stuff and you're
gonna be part of the show as i said
we'll do q and a's we'll do some skypes
we'll talk to
we'll talk to experts and we'll talk to
regular people and i'll give you
my analysis on what's going on on the
day and my hope is that by the end of it
you don't have a headache but you feel a
little more enlightened and a little
more
like everything's going to be okay
because i really believe that it will be
so that is it that is reuben report
direct message
episode one we're back tomorrow at 11
a.m pacific
you